When Adam was a junior in high school, living in New York, he got invited to this party that he was petrified to go to. The kids not only seemed more grown-up, they talked about how grown-up they were. And when he got there, there was no dancing or goofing around. Everyone just sat around a coffee table, about a dozen kids, casually drinking beers, just talking.
亚当读高二时住在纽约，他被邀请去参加一个派对，但他非常害怕去。那些孩子不仅看起来更成熟，而且还在谈论他们有多成熟。当他到达那里时，并没有人在跳舞或瞎闹。十几岁的孩子们只是随意地坐在咖啡桌旁，喝着啤酒，闲聊着。
I don't remember exactly what we talked about, but I just remember it was all very quiet, and people would sort of nod while you were talking.
我不记得我们具体聊了些什么，但我只记得当时非常安静，当你说话时，大家会点头示意。
And during this very grown-up party, a party unlike any Adam had ever been to, a couple got up and left the room for a while.
在这个非常“成熟”的派对上——一个亚当从未参加过的派对——有一对男女起身离开了房间一段时间。
At some point I realized that they were in the bedroom for quite some time.
在某个时刻，我意识到他们在卧室里待了很久。
With the door closed.
门关着。
With the door closed. And I mean, we were 16. I'm kind of-- you know, nobody was giggling, nobody was observing this fact, nobody was making mention of this. I mean it was just what adults do. It was just, this is what you do at a party.
门关着。我是说，我们才16岁。我当时有点……你知道，没有人嬉笑，没有人对此议论，没有人提起这件事。我的意思是，这简直就是成年人的做法。这就像是你在派对上该做的事。
After a while, the boy and girl walked from the bedroom to the bathroom, and they showered together. Then, the boy, wearing a terrycloth bathrobe, rejoined the party. And as Adam went to more parties with this crowd, this would happen a lot. A couple would go off, have sex, and then return to the party, all the while everyone acting like this was no big deal at all.
过了一会儿，那个男孩和女孩从卧室走到浴室，一起洗了澡。然后，那个穿着毛巾浴袍的男孩回到了派对。随着亚当越来越多地参加这类聚会，这种事情经常发生。一对男女离开去发生关系，然后回到派对，而所有人表现得好像这根本没什么大不了的。
At that time, did you think, OK, well, this is the way that adults act?
当时，你有没有想过，好吧，这就是成年人的行事方式？
Yeah, it was all so mysterious. I would have kind of bought anything about those things, you know? I didn't really-- it seemed to me like this is how sophisticated, cool adults were. I mean, the crucial thing was nothing was a big deal. Nothing was worth commenting on.
是的，一切都太神秘了。关于那些事情，我几乎会相信任何说法，你知道吗？我真的……在我看来，这就是成熟、酷炫的成年人的样子。我的意思是，最关键的是，任何事情都不算什么大事。没有什么值得评论的。
Of course, why would you want to be prematurely blase about sex? Well, part of being a kid is wanting to be a grown-up already. And throughout childhood, from a very early age, you try on various adult behaviors for size. You rehearse being an adult long before you get the part full time. And sometimes, in these rehearsals, you just get it wrong.
当然，为什么你会想在还没长大时就对性表现得漠不关心呢？好吧，身为孩子的一部分就是渴望早点成为大人。在整个童年时期，从很小的时候起，你就会尝试各种成年人的行为。你在真正成为大人之前，很久就开始排练扮演成年人。有时，在这些排练中，你只会做错。
Today in our program, stories of kids trying to act like adults, sometimes by their own choice, sometimes because they have no choice, and what they get right, and wrong. From WBEZ Chicago, and Public Radio International, It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass.
今天在我们的节目中，我们要讲一些孩子们试图表现得像大人的故事，有时是他们自己的选择，有时是因为他们别无选择，以及他们做对了什么，又做错了什么。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台和国际公共广播电台，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Act One of our program today, I Was a Teenage Ambulance Driver, in which we ask the question, can it be good for you as a kid to see some things that you just don't want to see? Act Two, Househusband at 12. The story of two brothers escaping Vietnam, and how one ended up doing the cooking and cleaning for the other.
我们今天节目的第一幕《我曾是一名少年救护车司机》，我们要问这样一个问题：作为孩子，经历一些你根本不想看到的事情，这对你有好处吗？第二幕《12岁的家庭煮夫》。讲述两个兄弟逃离越南的故事，以及其中一个是如何最终为另一个做饭和打扫卫生的。
Act Three, The Miseducation of Josh Frank, in which an average American 17-year-old explains why it's OK to ignore everything you're supposed to like about high school and start your career in the big city. Act Four, Angry Young Man, Times Two. What it's like to be a teenager sent to a maximum security prison, and what it's like to be an adult working with kids like that knowing it could have been you? Stay with us.
第三幕《乔什·弗兰克的误导》，一位普通的美国17岁少年解释为什么无视那些高中里所谓的“你应该喜欢”的事物，直接在大城市开始你的职业生涯是可以的。第四幕《愤怒的年轻人，乘以二》。作为一名少年被送进最高安全级别的监狱是什么感觉？作为一名与这样的孩子一起工作的成年人，意识到如果换做你可能也会那样，又是什么感觉？请继续收听。
Act one, I was a teenaged ambulance driver. Mike Paternini has this story, that takes place way back in the late 20th century.
第一幕，我曾是一名少年救护车司机。迈克·帕特尼蒂讲述了这个故事，它发生在20世纪后期。
I was a teenage ambulance driver. In my Connecticut hometown, people thought it might be wise to put their suburban youngsters to good use. And so post '53, a youth ambulance service was established. We, the acne-plagued, gum-chewing, beer-sneaking generation-to-be thought this was remarkably wise. One day, you were bumping your back wheel over a curve, nervously trying to parallel park over at the DMV, and the next, you are commanding several tons of bucking red siren emergency love, screaming like a banshee down the interstate. And everybody, everybody, was curtsying and swerving, and pulling over to let you pass. You checking these strobes, dude? Adios, suckers.
我曾是一名少年救护车司机。在我康涅狄格州的家乡，人们认为让郊区的年轻人发挥余热可能是明智之举。因此在53年后，一个青年救护车服务机构成立了。我们这代满脸痘痘、嚼着口香糖、偷喝啤酒的未来一代，认为这非常英明。前一天，你还在练车场上笨拙地倒车，紧张地试图侧方停车，下一刻，你就在驾驶着几吨重的红灯闪烁的紧急救援车，在州际公路上像女妖一样尖叫着呼啸而过。所有人，所有人都不得不减速避让，靠边停车让你先行。你看到那些频闪灯了吗，哥们？再见啦，傻瓜们。
The post was housed in an old railroad station that shook any time a Metro north train blew by on the way to Manhattan, or back to New Haven. And there we were, this secret cabal of 50 or so high school kids, girls and boys, most of us achievers of one kind or another, most of us on a path to college. Away from the post, we might drink or smoke pot, listen to Neil Young, or The Clash. On a call, there was none of that.
站点设在一个旧火车站里，每当大都会北方铁路的火车鸣笛开往曼哈顿或回纽黑文时，车站就会震动。我们就待在那里，这个由大约50名高中生组成的秘密集团，男女都有，我们大多数人在某方面都颇有成就，大多数人都在通往大学的路上。在站点之外，我们可能会喝酒或抽大麻，听尼尔·杨或“冲撞”乐队的歌。但只要一出车，就绝不会这样。
There were usually four of us riding in the ambulance, an EMT, a gopher, the driver, and often an adult supervisor, though occasionally, the supervisor was just a more experienced high school senior. We dressed in white button down shirts and white pants with fluorescent orange jackets. At school, we carried big clunky pagers, and sometimes we were called from class to respond to a car accident, or a stroke, or whatever else might be going wrong with a human body in our town.
通常有四个人坐在救护车上：一名急救人员（EMT）、一个打杂的、一名司机，有时还有一名成年主管，尽管有时主管只是一个更有经验的高中生。我们穿着白衬衫和白裤子，外面套着荧光橙色的夹克。在学校里，我们带着笨重的大寻呼机，有时我们会被从课堂上叫走去处理车祸、中风，或是镇上人类身体可能发生的任何其他糟糕状况。
The person responsible for our teenage ambulance service, the post, was a celebrated man in town named Bud Doble, who had a habit of calling each and every one of us Booby, and usually not as a term of endearment. "What the hell do you think you're doing, Booby?" he would roar. "Did anyone tell you we're dealing with human lives here?" He kept us on the straight and narrow, our very own Patton, and we, his boobies, attended endless training sessions where we learned to do our jobs with military efficiency.
负责我们少年救护车服务（站点）的人，是镇上一位名人，名叫巴德·多布尔。他有个习惯，称呼我们每个人为“笨蛋”（Booby），而且通常不是亲昵的称呼。“你到底在搞什么鬼，笨蛋？”他会咆哮道。“有没有人告诉过你，我们处理的是人命？”他让我们保持正轨，就像我们自己的巴顿将军。而我们这些“笨蛋”们，参加了无数的培训，学习如何以军事化的效率完成工作。
Our lives revolved around this old train station, cluttered with Styrofoam coffee cups and our backpacks strewn in every corner. On duty until midnight, we'd hang out, waiting for a call, get pizza, flirt. We weren't expected to be at home, and the beauty of it was that all this pizza-eating, and flirting, and teenage goofing around was sanctioned by the selfless effort we were making on behalf of our town. There were times when you felt a little like you were getting away with something huge. Other times, you weren't so sure.
我们的生活围绕着这个旧火车站，到处是聚苯乙烯咖啡杯，背包散落在各个角落。在午夜下班前，我们会闲逛，等待电话，吃披萨，调情。我们不需要待在家里，而最美妙的是，所有这些吃披萨、调情和少年的瞎闹，都是以我们为小镇所做的无私奉献之名而被认可的。有时你会觉得自己在占某种天大的便宜。而有时，你又不那么确定。
Once, I got a beeper call to a classroom at my own school. My physics teacher, who was full of quacky bluster during the 50 minutes we spent with him each day, who took exceptional glee in scrawling a C-minus at the top of a pop quiz after you'd bombed, stood alone in his lab, trembling, his nose bleeding uncontrollably, bright red blood streaking his white turtleneck like Chinese characters.
有一次，我接到寻呼机传来的消息，要去我自己的学校教室。我的物理老师——他在我们每天上的50分钟课里总是满口古怪的吹嘘，在抓到你考试考砸时喜欢在试卷顶端歪歪扭扭地写下“C-”——当时独自站在实验室里颤抖，鼻血无法控制地流着，鲜红的血液像汉字一样流在他白色的高领毛衣上。
He seemed mortified, both by what was happening to him and by who had come to help. Later, when he was back to his healthy self, lording his vast knowledge of physics over us, I would sit in the class on a particularly grueling day of him making us feel small, and flash back to that moment when he stood covered in blood. And I don't know, I'm not proud to say, it kind of helped me through.
他看起来感到羞愧，既因为发生在他身上的事，也因为是谁来救他。后来，当他恢复健康，继续在我们面前摆弄他那渊博的物理知识时，每当他在艰难的日子里让我们感到渺小时，我都会想起他浑身是血站在那里的瞬间。我不知道，我也不以此为荣，但那真的在某种程度上帮我挺过来了。
If teenage rebellion is based on the fact that adults are dangerous, that they control you and can get you in trouble, that teachers, and cops, and even your parents , are not like you in any way, but are a different species altogether, what happens when you're put in a position where they're suddenly weak, and you suddenly have the power? Can you ever go back to being a teenager again?
如果说青少年的叛逆源于成年人是危险的、他们控制着你、能让你陷入麻烦，源于老师、警察甚至你的父母和你完全不同，是一个完全不同的物种，那么当你被置于一个位置，让他们突然变得软弱，而你突然拥有了权力时，会发生什么呢？你还能回到那个普通的少年吗？
Once, late on a week night, I was on another call outside a bar on the main street of our town. When we arrived, a man was down by the shoulder of the road, struggling to get up. He'd been hit by a car. He was dirty and drunk, slurring his words. He was clearly hurt, probably had some internal bleeding, though adrenalin and booze had convinced him he was fine. I remember holding a flashlight and shining it on him, and him saying, "Get that [BLEEP] light off of me. I'll be damned if I'm going to have the kiddie docs take me away."
有一次，深夜，我在我们镇主街的一家酒吧外接到了另一次出警。当我们到达时，一个男人躺在路肩旁，挣扎着想起来。他被车撞了。他身上很脏，喝醉了，说话含糊不清。他显然受了伤，可能还有内出血，尽管肾上腺素和酒精让他坚信自己没事。我记得我拿着手电筒照着他，他说：“把那该死的光移开。我才不要被这帮小医生带走。”
To my surprise, he was my old swim coach, someone whose generosity and ferocity on a pool deck had shaped my early years as a swimmer. And though I hadn't seen him in a few years, he was someone I'd revered. "Coach," I said, "It's Mike Paterniti. I was one of your swimmers." "I'm not going," he said, "don't touch me." "Listen, coach, I think it would be best if you came." "I think you can go [BLEEP] yourself," he said.
令我惊讶的是，他是我以前的游泳教练，一个在泳池边以慷慨和严厉塑造了我早年游泳生涯的人。尽管我已经有几年没见他了，但他一直是我敬仰的人。“教练，”我说，“我是迈克·帕特尼蒂。我是你带过的游泳队员之一。”“我不走，”他说，“别碰我。”“听着，教练，我想你最好跟我们走。”“我觉得你可以滚蛋了，”他说。
"I was one of your swimmers," I said again, "and you're hurt." He tried to focus, but couldn't. My name didn't register. And why should it have? He'd been thrown headfirst into an embankment, and had a tuft of sod unwittingly stuck to his head like a sad beret. "Get away from me!" he said. "Before I make you hurt."
“我是你的队员之一，”我再次说，“你受伤了。”他试图集中注意力，但做不到。我的名字没能让他想起什么。而他为什么要记得呢？他头朝下撞进了路基，一簇草皮无意间粘在他的头上，像一顶悲伤的贝雷帽。“离我远点！”他说，“不然我就让你吃苦头。”
Make me hurt? It seemed a bizarre thing to say, but I backed off. He signed a waiver that he was refusing treatment, and we left him there, broken and beginning to sob when I turned my back on him. I remember being confused by that, by his belligerence and vulnerability, by the way he was so completely not the man I once thought he was, the man I'd pinned some hope on, and some sense of my own self. And I knew that he wasn't sobbing because he'd been hit by a car, or was drunk. Something else had led him to this moment, but I didn't even try to ponder what.
让我吃苦头？这听起来很古怪，但我后退了。他签了拒绝治疗的弃权书，我们把他留在了那里。当我转身离开时，他已经破碎并开始啜泣。我记得我对那一幕感到困惑，对他的好战与脆弱感到困惑，对他是那么彻底地不再是我曾经认为的那个人，那个我寄托了希望和某种自我意识的人，感到困惑。我知道他啜泣不是因为被车撞了，也不是因为喝醉了。是别的东西把他引向了这一刻，但我甚至没有尝试去深究是什么。
One of my brothers, Steve, was in post, too, and after I left for college, he became president, a kind of big deal at the time. Though he briefly ended up as the whitest angel, my brother was actually more of a rebel than I was in those days. Recently, I asked him what he remembered of that time. "The outfits," he said, laughing. We started trading stories about the calls we'd been on.
我的兄弟史蒂夫也曾在站点工作，我上大学后，他成了主席，在当时算是个大人物。虽然他最终成了最纯洁的天使，但在那个年代，我的兄弟其实比我更叛逆。最近，我问他还记得那段时光吗。“那身制服，”他笑着说。我们开始交换彼此出警的故事。
You know, the one I remember, that I've had recurring memories and dreams of, is this accident up by that really bad 90 degree curve, up by Weburn, you know, on Hollow Tree? With this mother who was driving in a VW Rabbit, and she had two twin boys, four years old. And they were kicking each other in the back or something, so she reached back to stop them, and drove right into a stone wall. And one of the boys was OK, and the other one was hurt really badly. He had a huge swelling in his forehead, really big, and when we came to the scene, I was the EMT.
你知道，我记得的那件事，至今仍会在记忆和梦中反复出现，是那个发生在韦伯恩附近那条非常糟糕的90度弯道上的事故，就在空心树路（Hollow Tree）上，你记得吗？当时一位母亲开着一辆大众兔牌轿车，载着两个四岁的双胞胎男孩。他们可能在后座踢来踢去，所以她伸手想去阻止他们，结果直接撞上了一堵石墙。其中一个男孩没事，另一个伤得很重。他的前额肿起了一个大包，非常大。当我们到达现场时，我是那名急救员。
And just this guy who had driven by stopped to see if he could help, and had grabbed the four year old, the hurt one, out of the car, which obviously you're not supposed to do, because we didn't know if he had a neck injury. And he came running over to me with this little boy. And so I had to grab the kid in my hands, in my arms, and take him into the ambulance. And his mother was a nurse, and she kept saying, just tell me, just tell me what's wrong. Just tell me, I know something, I know this is serious, I know this is serious.
刚好有个开车经过的人停下来看看能否帮忙，他把那个受伤的四岁男孩从车里拽了出来，显然这是你不该做的，因为我们不知道他是否颈部受伤。他抱着小男孩跑向我。我不得不从他怀里接过孩子，抱进救护车。孩子的母亲是位护士，她不停地说，告诉我，告诉我他怎么了。告诉我，我知道发生了什么，我知道这很严重，我知道这很严重。
So my brother had to figure out what to do. There were no obvious broken bones or lacerations, which made the situation altogether more ominous. He suspected that there might be severe internal injuries, and so they needed to get the kid to the hospital, fast.
所以我的兄弟必须想办法应对。没有明显的骨折或撕裂伤，这让情况显得更加不祥。他怀疑可能有严重的内伤，所以他们必须尽快把孩子送到医院。
I remember his little fingers. He was stiff, but his hands were moving. And he would he would grab my pinkie and squeeze it tight. And that was just pretty intense, to think this is up to me, here, maybe. As it turned out, he ended up dying, of, I think, massive, massive head injuries. Brain injuries.
我记得他细小的手指。他的身体僵硬，但手在动。他会抓住我的小指紧紧捏住。想到这一切可能都取决于我，这感觉非常强烈。结果，他最终死于……我想，巨大的头部损伤。脑部损伤。
And I also remember, when I got to the hospital, we wheeled the stretcher off and ran him in, one of the people in the E.R. came out, and said to me, "Well, why didn't you tell us it was this kind of injury, and a head injury, we would have had the brain trauma center set up," and stuff. And I was like, at that point I was thinking, oh my god. If I didn't tell them something I should have told them, and I wasted five minutes that could have saved this kid's life, I was just devastated.
我也记得，当我到达医院时，我们推着担架把他冲了进去，急诊室里有人出来对我说：“好吧，你为什么不告诉我们是这种伤？如果是头部损伤，我们就会准备好脑部创伤中心了。”之类的。那时我在想，天哪。如果我有什么应该告诉他们却没说，浪费了五分钟本可以挽救这孩子生命的时间，我当时简直崩溃了。
I know I told them everything that I saw, I know I said that he had a swelling over his head. Whether or not I sufficiently flagged it for them, I don't know. I mean, I don't know. I felt awful. It was pretty hard to deal with for a little while. I mean, I can deal with it now. And it's not something I think about every day. But I definitely felt guilty that maybe he wouldn't have died, or something.
我知道我告诉了他们我所看到的一切，我知道我说过他的头部有肿块。我是否充分向他们强调了这一点，我不知道。我是说，我不知道。我感觉糟糕透了。那件事有一段时间很难释怀。现在我能处理了。这不是我每天都会想的事情。但我确实感到内疚，也许他本来不会死的。
What's curious is that we never really talked about calls like that. Not in any great detail, and never to anyone outside of the post, especially our parents. And so my brother's worst calls were bottled and stored in the cellar of his psyche, only to haunt him these years later in bad dreams. In fact, until now, I had never even asked Steve about another incident that occurred when the two of us were at home, on a day near the end of the school year when I was a senior and he was a junior.
奇怪的是，我们从不真正谈论那样的出警。没有细节，也不对站点之外的任何人说，特别是我们的父母。于是，我兄弟最糟糕的出警经历都被装进瓶子，储存在他心理的深窖里，多年后才在噩梦中困扰他。事实上，直到现在，我甚至从未问过史蒂夫关于另一件发生在家里的小事。那是高中最后一年快结束时，我是高三，他是高二。
That afternoon, I was engaged in heavy combat with my youngest brother, Rich, who was eight years old at the time. Rich had uncanny hand-eye coordination, and was a merciless video game player, the supreme universal master of Asteroids. I had made a promise to myself that before graduating high school, I would find a way to beat him. And by some cosmic fluke, never to be repeated, I was. I was creaming him, and neither of us could believe it.
那天下午，我正在和我最小的兄弟里奇进行激烈的搏斗，他当时才八岁。里奇有着惊人的手眼协调能力，是一个冷酷无情的电子游戏玩家，是《小行星》游戏的最高主宰。我曾对自己许下诺言，在高中毕业前，我要找到击败他的方法。凭借某种宇宙级的侥幸——绝不会再有第二次——我做到了。我正在狂虐他，我们俩都不敢相信。
Which is when our next door neighbor, a woman just older than my mother, burst in. Her 75 year old father had keeled over on the lawn in cardiac arrest. I remember my first thought was, but I'm about to kick Rich's butt. And then I started outside, telling her to get Steve, who was upstairs listening to music in his room.
就在这时，我们的邻居，一位比我母亲大一点的妇女，冲了进来。她75岁的父亲在草坪上突发心脏病倒下了。我记得我的第一个念头是：但我正要打败里奇啊。然后我跑向外面，让她去找史蒂夫，他当时正在楼上房间听音乐。
I mean, I could probably remember the song I was listening to if I thought. I think it was probably Bob Marley, Babylon by Bus .
我的意思是，如果我想的话，大概能记起我当时听的是什么歌。我想大概是鲍勃·马利的《巴比伦之行》（Babylon by Bus）。
I remember running outside to our neighbor's father, and beginning CPR. I remember something happening that I didn't expect at all, his ribs separating from his sternum, and breaking easily under the weight of my palm. A muffled cracking sound.
我记得跑到邻居父亲身边，开始心肺复苏。我记得发生了一件我完全没预料到的事，他的肋骨在我的掌压下，轻易地与胸骨分离并断裂了。那种闷响。
I just remember the feel of the guy's beard on my lips. Then you have pretty normal reactions. How could I possibly think a video game is more important, or how could I possibly be angry at being pulled away from listening to a record to have to try to save someone's life? But you definitely have those-- I definitely remember having those reactions. I remember hearing that, in that sort of perfect early summer afternoon, listening to the perfect music, and just coming down the stairs and seeing her face, and knowing that something was going to happen. Or something had happened, bad. It's sort of the same feeling, almost like a little tiny bit of resentment. Well, that just blew the afternoon in a big way. And then feeling, of course, real guilty about having that feeling later.
我只记得嘴唇接触到那个人胡须的感觉。然后你会有很正常的反应。我怎么能觉得电子游戏更重要呢？或者怎么会因为被从听唱片中拉出来去试图挽救一个人的生命而生气呢？但你确实会有那些反应——我确实记得有过那种反应。我记得在那个完美的初夏午后的那种声音，听着完美的音乐，然后下楼看到她脸上的表情，就知道会发生什么了。或者说，坏事已经发生了。这是一种类似的感觉，几乎带有一点点怨恨。好吧，那彻底毁了整个下午。然后，当然，后来为自己有这种想法感到非常内疚。
This was the thing about the post. It represented two totally discordant and opposite teenage impulses. On the one hand, we still wanted to act like kids, but then at the same time, we wanted to be adults. We'd accepted the ultimate adult responsibility, riding in an ambulance and being held accountable for human lives.
这就是关于“站点”的事。它代表了两种完全不和谐且对立的少年冲动。一方面，我们仍然想表现得像孩子，但同时，我们又渴望成为大人。我们接受了最终的成年责任：坐上救护车，并对人的生命负责。
I would have been 17 years old at the time of my last serious call. It was spring of my senior year, and all I wanted was to hang out with my girlfriend-- just get lost, and forget every last adult thing looming on the horizon. You know, the specter of going away to college, and then after that, the requirement of finding some kind of worthy job, and the ensuing money grief, and whatever it was that adults worried about all the time.
在我最后一次严重出警时，我大约17岁。那是高三那年的春天，我想要的只是和女朋友待在一起——迷失自我，忘掉地平线上所有逼近的成年琐事。你知道，去上大学的阴影，在那之后，寻找一份体面工作的需求，随之而来的金钱痛苦，以及成年人总是担心的任何事情。
But I was on duty, getting ready to go home, actually, when the call came in. A car accident, out on Pear Tree Point, which juts out into Long Island Sound. There are huge beautiful trees out there, and a girl not much older than me had run headlong into one of them, drunk.
但我当时值班，实际上正准备回家，电话就打进来了。一次车祸，在梨树角（Pear Tree Point），那里突入长岛海峡。那里有巨大的、美丽的树，一个年纪没比我大多少的女孩喝醉后直接撞上了一棵。
It was a dark night. When we arrived, we couldn't find her at first. We were all out looking in the ditch by the road. And then suddenly, I was at the car. What had been the car, as the whole front end was flattened. I remember somehow opening the jammed front door, and seeing a trapped woman, head down on the steering wheel, her hair long and blonde, her body splattered with blood. And she was moaning, a low, sickly, almost reflexive moan.
那是一个黑暗的夜晚。我们到达时，起初没找到她。我们都在路边的沟里找。然后突然，我到了车边。那已经不能称之为车了，因为整个车头都被压扁了。我记得不知怎么打开了卡住的前门，看到一个被困的女人，头垂在方向盘上，金色的长发，全身溅满了血。她在呻吟，一种低沉的、病态的、几乎是条件反射般的呻吟。
I remember taking her head in my hands to pull traction, and lifting her back, and then almost throwing up at what I saw. I don't know how to put this gently, but she didn't have a face. That is, her nose had been driven into her head, and there was a huge gash on her forehead from which something brainy was leaking. And her jaw hung half-loose. And her eyes had rolled completely back, were just these white ghostly things reflecting nothing.
我记得把她的头捧在手里进行牵引，抬起她的背，然后因为我看到的景象差点吐出来。我不知道该如何委婉地表达，但她没有脸了。也就是说，她的鼻子被撞进了脑子里，前额有一个巨大的裂口，里面有什么像脑组织的东西在渗出。她的下巴半脱落着。她的眼睛完全翻了过去，只是那种反射不出任何东西的、苍白的幽灵般的物体。
In EMT training, you're taught that once you've begun to pull traction, you can't like go. And so I can't tell you how long I sat face to face with this woman. Even after we put on a neck brace, I held her head, for hours. And she moaned, and moaned, and I, too, begin to moan quietly to myself.
在急救训练中，你会学到一旦开始牵引，就不能松手。所以我无法告诉你我和这个女人面对面坐了多久。即使在我们戴上颈托后，我也捧着她的头，持续了几个小时。她呻吟着，呻吟着，我也开始对着自己低声呻吟。
The fire department was called, and other ambulances with the capability to administer drugs. And the jaws of life were used to pry her loose, finally. Bud Doble came too, as he often did to the bad ones. After several hours, after a huge crowd had gathered, we got her out and wheeled her to another ambulance. And since I'd been with her at the beginning, I stayed with her until the end.
消防部门被叫来了，还有其他有能力提供药物的救护车。最后，“生命之钳”被用来把她撬出来。巴德·多布尔也来了，像对待严重的事故一样。几个小时后，在一大群人围观下，我们把她弄出来，推到了另一辆救护车上。既然从一开始我就和她在一起，我就一直陪着她直到最后。
I remember standing up on the back fender at the back door as they stripped her naked and shot her full of drugs. And I remember a stream of her blood running down the floor of that ambulance, over my white Reeboks. Bud Doble was standing next to me, shaking his head. Tough one, he said. By morning, she was dead.
我记得当时站在救护车后门的踏板上，看着他们剥掉她的衣服，给她注射药物。我记得她的一股血流过救护车的地板，流到了我白色的锐步运动鞋上。巴德·多布尔站在我旁边，摇着头。他说，“棘手的一案。”到了早晨，她死了。
When I got home that night, my dad was up waiting. And though I wanted to tell him what had happened, I didn't. Or couldn't. I don't know why. I just stood for a while, making small talk, and then I went up to bed.
那天晚上我回到家，我爸爸还没睡。虽然我想告诉他发生了什么，但我没说。或者说，无法开口。我不知道为什么。我就站了一会儿，随便聊了几句，然后上楼睡觉去了。
But here's the thing I remember most about that night. Somehow, the girl's parents had heard about the accident, and made it to the crash site. And then they were moving toward the back of the ambulance to see their daughter, the one they'd raised and loved. Bud Doble glanced over his shoulder, knew exactly who they were, and leaped down. I remember he wrapped his arms around both of them, talked to them in a low voice, comforting them. He covered them both up, and led them straight away, the three of them in a bear hug. Here was this stranger, and they clung to him like Jesus.
但这就是我关于那天晚上记忆最深的事情。不知怎么的，女孩的父母听说了事故，赶到了现场。然后他们正走向救护车后面，想看看他们的女儿，那个他们养大并爱着的女儿。巴德·多布尔回头瞥了一眼，确切地知道他们是谁，于是跳了下来。我记得他用双臂抱住了他们两个，低声对他们说话，安慰他们。他覆盖住他们两人，领着他们径直走开，三人抱成一团。这就是这个陌生人，而他们像依赖耶稣一样紧紧依附着他。
I thought about that woman and her parents last week, when I myself was at the hospital for the birth of my first child. Already, I was imagining a life for him. His first words, his first steps, his first day of school, his first bike, his first girlfriend, his first act of rebellion. I imagined what secret worlds he might occupy one day, and whether he would ever tell his father about them. From our room at the hospital, we happened to look down on the ambulances as they came and went from the emergency room. And standing with my one day old son in my arms, I watched.
上周我生下第一个孩子时，我想到了那个女人和她的父母。我已经开始为他想象生活了。他的第一句话，第一步，第一天上学，第一辆自行车，第一个女朋友，第一次叛逆。我想象他将来会占据什么样的秘密世界，他是否会向他的父亲讲述这些。在医院的病房里，我们碰巧俯瞰到救护车进出急诊室。抱着出生一天的儿子，我看着。
I watched the paramedics wheel in all sorts of people, and return with empty stretchers, joking with each other. I stood in the window with my son in my arms like a man on a beach, watching others bob in a distant ocean, diving on a coral reef. It was late afternoon, and the sun dropped down behind some low clouds, lighting the parking lot silver. I watched as an ambulance driver ran to his rig, flipped on his strobes, and floored it, off to some new disaster, to some broken body out there somewhere. It was an old reflex, I admit, but I turned my son from the window and raised his mouth to my ear, just to make sure I could feel his breath.
我看着急救人员推入各种各样的人，又带着空担架回来，互相开着玩笑。我抱着儿子站在窗前，像个站在海滩上的人，看着远处海洋里沉浮的其他人，潜入珊瑚礁。那是傍晚，太阳落入低云后，把停车场照得银光闪闪。我看着一名救护车司机跑向他的车，打开频闪灯，猛踩油门，赶往某个新的灾难，赶往外面的某个破碎的身体。那是一种老习惯，我承认，但我把儿子从窗前转过来，把他的嘴贴在我的耳边，只是为了确认我能感受到他的呼吸。
Mike Paterniti lives in Portland, Maine, with family.
迈克·帕特尼蒂与家人住在缅因州的波特兰。
[MUSIC - "ALMOST GROWN" BY CHUCK BERRY]
[音乐 - 查克·贝里的《几乎长大》]
Act Two, Househusband at 12.
第二幕，《12岁的家庭煮夫》。
So what if you made the most important decision of your life when you were 12 years old, and for all the wrong reasons? When Anh Tuan Hoang was 12, back in 1980, living in Vietnam, his cousin was scheming up a way to escape the country by boat. It would be 36 people, hidden in a tiny craft. Anh Tuan's older brother was invited on the trip because he knew how to fix engines, which everyone figured might come in handy. And Anh Tuan was invited too. And he wanted to go, but for reasons that had very little to do with reality, and everything to do with the way that a kid sees the world.
如果说你在12岁时，却因各种错误的理由做出了人生中最重要的决定，会怎样？当安图安·黄（Anh Tuan Hoang）1980年12岁生活在越南时，他的表亲正策划通过船只逃离这个国家。那将是36个人，挤在一艘极小的船里。安图安的哥哥被邀请参加，因为他懂修理引擎，大家觉得这可能会派上用场。安图安也被邀请了。他想去，但原因与现实几乎毫无关系，而与孩子看世界的方式息息相关。
For me, having a chance, an opportunity to travel-- because to travel in Vietnam at the time was extremely difficult. So just to have an opportunity to leave the city, maybe go to North Vietnam, because we were planning to escape from North Vietnam, I thought it would be a cool thing. And then, I thought, escaping, you'll be caught. It's not that easy.
对我来说，有机会去旅行——因为当时在越南旅行极其困难。所以只要有机会离开城市，也许去北越，因为我们计划从北越逃离，我觉得那会是很酷的事。然后，我想，逃跑的话会被抓住的。那可没那么容易。
But really, you thought you would get caught and be sent back.
但实际上，你以为你会由于被捕而被遣返。
Yeah.
是的。
You didn't actually think you were going to be leaving Vietnam?
你其实并不认为你会离开越南？
Right. Not exactly. Like in my mind, I didn't think I would be able to. So for me, it's just like, I love my mom, I can't be separated from her, but this is not really true. This is a game. I'm going to go and enjoy the visit, and then be caught, and sent back to my family. And then my mom has a totally different idea. She's thinking, he's leaving, either he make it, I'll never see him again. I might, you know, in the late, late future. If he get caught, they might kill him. Or, you know, the chance of being dead at the sea is great, too.
对。并不完全是。就像在我的脑海里，我不认为我能做到。所以对我来说，这就像……我爱我的妈妈，我离不开她，但这并不是真的。这是一个游戏。我要去享受这次旅行，然后被抓住，被送回我的家人身边。但我妈的想法完全不同。她在想，他要离开了，要么他成功了，我再也见不到他了。如果他被抓了，他们可能会杀了他。或者，你知道，在海上死亡的几率也很大。
So she was truly petrified. And she didn't want to let me go, because I was really young, and I was a baby. And then he has to sort of convince, and then my brother and my whole family sort of talked to my mom, and said, mom, look, you know, there's a war going on with Cambodia right now. They're drafting young men. As soon as you reach your 17th birthday, they take you. And then, plus, if I had stayed behind, I would never been able to get ahead. And I wouldn't been able to go to college, for example, or to get a decent job.
所以她真的吓坏了。她不想让我走，因为我还太小，还是个婴儿。然后他不得不说服，我的哥哥和我的整个家庭都试图劝说我妈妈，说：“妈，你看，你知道现在正和柬埔寨打仗。他们在征召年轻人。你一到17岁，他们就会带走你。”再者，如果我留在后面，我就永远没有出头之日。比如，我将无法上大学，或者找到一份体面的工作。
So after a lot of convincing, my mom just decided. She said, OK, you can go, it would be good for your future. But one thing I remember her telling me, she said, you can have a better future and everything, but you just never find the love that I have for you. I'm your mother. And after that, it was sort of odd, because she didn't really speak to me very much until the day I leave. It was too difficult for her. She's like, pretend that nothing is going to happen.
在多方劝说后，我妈妈决定了。她说：“好吧，你可以去，这对你的未来有好处。”但我记得她告诉我的一件事，她说：“你可以拥有更好的未来，拥有一切，但你永远找不到我对你的那种爱。我是你的母亲。”那之后，一切变得有点奇怪，因为直到我离开的那天，她几乎没怎么跟我说话。这太难为她了。她就像是，假装什么都不会发生。
Now, as an adult, you must know how risky it was. Is it one out of two people who would get onto a boat wouldn't survive?
现在作为一个成年人，你一定知道这有多危险。登上船的人中，是不是每两个人就有一个无法生还？
Yeah, I mean, the odds of being survive is really, really small. It's either like I said, the boat is tipped over, you get caught by the government, or you being attacked by pirates.
是的，我是说，生还的几率真的非常非常小。要么像我说的，船翻了，要么被政府抓获，或者被海盗袭击。
Pirates?
海盗？
I mean, yeah, especially in South Vietnam.
我是说，是的，特别是在南越。
Were you scared?
你害怕吗？
I don't know if I can say I was scared. I mean, I was excited. I don't think I really got scared until I was on the boat. Then reality sort of sunk in.
我不知道能不能说我害怕。我是说，我很兴奋。我不认为直到我在船上时我才真正害怕。那时现实才沉入脑海。
So what happened when you got on the boat?
那么当你上船后发生了什么？
I got really sick. That was the first thing. And I just got really sick. I mean, I have never been on a boat going to the ocean. I've been on river boats in Saigon, no big deal. And I remember praying to just about all the saints, whomever I know just from growing up, so that I could die. Literally, I was like,  just let me die. This is just awful, I want to die.
我病得很厉害。那是第一件事。我真的病得很重。我是说，我以前从没坐船去过大海。我在西贡坐过河船，那没什么大不了的。我记得向我成长过程中认识的所有圣人祈祷，希望我能死掉。我简直是在想，就让我死吧。这太糟糕了，我想死。
And the first few days we did have some food that we take with us. We thought that it would take us six days to get from Hai Phong to Hong Kong. But this ended up taking us a lot longer than that because the boat broke down a lot, and also we encountered a storm.
头几天我们确实带了一些食物。我们以为从海防到香港只需要六天。但这最终花费的时间要长得多，因为船坏了很多次，而且我们还遇到了风暴。
We were stranded in an island for ten days. We had a little bit of food left for the island, but just barely. Like maybe a few handful of rice that we make very thin soup to drink. But we managed to find all kind of weird sea animals, and we ate those. I tried to eat grass, at one point, because I was so hungry. And found out that you can eat a lot of vegetation, you just can't eat grass. I don't know why. It's like it tastes horrible, you can't even swallow it.
我们在一个岛上被困了十天。我们还有一点点留给岛上的食物，但几乎没有了。可能只有几把米，我们做成稀薄的汤来喝。但我们设法找到了各种奇怪的海生动物，并吃了它们。有一次我试着吃草，因为我太饿了。结果发现你可以吃很多植物，但就是不能吃草。我不知道为什么。它尝起来太可怕了，你甚至无法吞咽。
And so you had planned that it would only take 6 days. How long did it end up taking?
所以你原本计划只需要6天。最后一共花了多久？
Almost two months.
将近两个月。
So two months go by, and where did you end up?
所以两个月过去了，你最终到了哪里？
Well, we end up in Hong Kong. And of course, you know, they know we were refugee. We'd looked like we were refugee. The boat was awful. So they took us into shore, into a warehouse. And basically bathed us, making sure that we were free of lice, and making sure that we had proper check-up, medical check-up. Then they take us to another camp, and the first month or so, we get some money to just get by, for the first month or so.
嗯，我们最终到了香港。当然，你知道，他们知道我们是难民。我们看起来就像难民。船的情况糟糕透了。所以他们把我们带上岸，带进了一个仓库。基本上给我们洗了澡，确保我们没有虱子，并确保我们进行了适当的医疗检查。然后他们把我们带到了另一个营地，第一个月左右，我们得到了一些钱来度日。
To buy food.
去买食物。
To buy food. But then after the first month, you have to work. And they will try to help you find jobs, outside in Hong Kong. Of course, the job that you would be getting paid very, very little. I'm talking like, maybe $0.50 cents an hour, or something.
去买食物。但第一个月后，你就必须工作。他们会设法帮你找工作，在香港外面。当然，你得到的工作报酬会非常非常少。我是说，可能每小时50美分之类的。
Now, for you, you were 12 years old. Is this is the first time you had a job?
那时候，你才12岁。这是你第一次找工作吗？
Well, I didn't have to work.
嗯，我不需要工作。
You didn't have to work.
你不需要工作。
I didn't have to work. But my brother did, because he have to take care of me. And since like I said we weren't really close, we didn't interact that well, I just felt left out, in a way. But then I felt like I had a responsibility, and that is to take care of my brother, in terms of making sure he get food, he get food to take to lunch, making sure his clothes are clean.
我不需要工作。但我哥哥必须工作，因为他得照顾我。正如我所说的，我们并没有那么亲密，我们的互动并不太好，我感到被排斥了。但后来我觉得我有责任，那就是照顾我哥哥，确保他有吃的，带去当午餐的食物，确保他的衣服是干净的。
And you're talking about having two pair of jeans, or two shirts. So you have to do them daily. You have to wash your clothes, you have to cook, go to the market. You have no refrigerator. I mean, you're talking about living in a concentration camp, again, with bunk beds. And that would be your room, two people. And you would hang pots and pans, and your clothes, everything, within that bunk bed. And at first, I was very scared. I mean, I didn't know a word of Chinese. Here, I have to go out of the camp, and say, I want a pound of beef, I want a kilo of rice. And it was hard. So I did a lot of that through pointing and hand signals.
你说的是只有两条牛仔裤或两件衬衫。所以你必须每天洗。你必须洗衣服，做饭，去市场。你没有冰箱。我是说，你是在集中营里生活，又是双层床。那就是你的房间，住两个人。你会把锅碗瓢盆和衣服都挂在那张双层床上。起初，我很害怕。我是说，我一个中文单词都不会说。在这里，我必须走出营地，说：“我要一磅牛肉，我要一公斤米。”这很难。所以我大部分时间都是通过指手画脚来完成的。
And had you ever cooked a meal before?
你以前做过饭吗？
No. I mean, growing up, I was sort of chased away from coming into the kitchen. My mom and sister were like, go, you know, go play somewhere. So I never really learned. So when I got there, it was like, basically, I have to do it. Otherwise, we'll be hungry. We can't afford to purchase already made meal. So I would ask people in the camp. I would watch them, watch older people cook, and learn how to do it.
没有。我是说，在成长过程中，我总是被从厨房里赶走。我妈妈和姐姐总是说：“走吧，去别处玩。”所以我从没真正学过。所以当我到那里时，基本上我必须做。否则，我们就会挨饿。我们负担不起买现成的饭菜。所以我不得不问营地里的人。我会观察他们，观察大人们如何做饭，然后学习怎么做。
Did you like the independence of shopping and cooking, and having this adult kind of life?
你喜欢那种购物、做饭，拥有这种成人般的生活的独立感吗？
Not really, because at that point, all I wanted to do was to have fun. For me, you have to understand, Hong Kong was new. It was kind of, wow, a huge city. And you are seeing 60 story buildings, and you are seeing all the neon lights, and the airplane, huge airplane flying. You know, the camp was very close to the airport. You are curious. You wanted to go out and just check around. It didn't cost anything. You can walk, play with your friend.
并不是，因为在那时，我只想找乐子。对我来说，你得明白，香港是全新的。那简直是……哇，巨大的城市。你看到60层高的大楼，看到所有的霓虹灯，飞机，巨大的飞机飞过。你知道，营地离机场很近。你很好奇。你想走出去看看周围。这不需要花钱。你可以走路，和朋友玩耍。
Do you think it was good for you to have to be such a grown up at such a young age?
你认为在那么小的年纪就必须表现得那么成熟对你有好处吗？
You know, my friends ask me that question a lot, and I am not sure how I would answer it, exactly. I think, I guess being forced to grow up so fast sometimes is sort of-- this is how I feel. It's probably different with different people. But I feel it left you feeling kind of insecure most of the time, because you never feel adequately supported by your parents guiding you through different things, or saying don't do this, do that. And so I always feel like I'm a child, in some way. I'm like 32, and sometimes I just feel like I'm a little kid.
你知道，我的朋友经常问我这个问题，我不知道该怎么准确回答。我想，被迫成长得那么快有时是……这就是我的感受。这可能因人而异。但我感觉这让你大部分时间感到不安全，因为你从未感到父母在引导你处理各种事情或告诉你别做这个做那个时，给你提供足够的支持。所以我总是觉得自己在某些方面还是个孩子。我已经32岁了，有时我觉得自己还是个小孩。
Knowing now what happened to you once you left in the boat, would you make the same choice again?
既然现在知道你离开后发生了什么，你还会做出同样的选择吗？
You know, probably not. Well of course, you can never say what happens to you, but I don't know. I just feel that if I have to do it, I probably wouldn't do it.
你知道，大概不会。好吧，当然，你永远无法预料会发生什么，但我不知道。我只是觉得如果必须这样做，我可能不会做。
Why?
为什么？
I don't know, I just think-- well, it's kind of a hard question, because I had to do it, so I did it. Just because I never get to see my mother. She passed away.
我不知道，我只是觉得……嗯，这是一个很难的问题，因为我必须这样做，所以我做了。只是因为我再也没能见到我母亲。她去世了。
She passed away after you left.
她在你离开后去世了。
After I left. This was after the year I graduate from college. I receive news that she passed away. So I regret that. I don't think you can have everything in life. Just back to what my mother said. You know, you can achieve all of this. You can have all the wealth, life can offer you all of these good things, but then sometimes you have to sacrifice a chunk of other things, like that love that your family can give you.
在我离开之后。那是在我大学毕业那年之后。我收到了她去世的消息。所以我后悔这一点。我不认为你能拥有生命中的一切。回到我母亲说的话。你知道，你可以实现所有这些。你可以拥有所有的财富，生活可以提供给你所有这些好东西，但有时你必须牺牲掉其他东西，比如家人能给你的那种爱。
Ahn  Tuan Hoang lives in Chicago. A Catholic charity brought him to the United States after a year and a half in Hong Kong. He's never been back to Vietnam. Coming up: anger and its uses, high school and its uses, and more. That's in a minute from Public Radio International when our program continues.
安图安·黄住在芝加哥。一个天主教慈善机构在他在香港待了一年半后将他带到了美国。他从未回过越南。接下来的节目：愤怒及其用途，高中的用途，等等。一分钟后，国际公共广播电台将继续我们的节目。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, stories of kids acting like adults-- some by choice, some because they're forced to. We've arrived at act three of our program. Act three, The Miseducation of Josh Frank. This is another story of a young person making a huge, life-changing decision about his own fate, while still very young. In this case, 13 years old. Hillary Frank tells the story, about her own little brother.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们都会选择一个主题，为您带来各种各样的关于该主题的故事。今天的节目是关于孩子们表现得像大人的故事——有些是自愿的，有些是因为被迫的。我们进入了节目的第三幕。《第三幕：乔什·弗兰克的误导》。这是另一个关于年轻人在很小时就对自己命运做出重大、改变人生决定的故事。在这种情况下，是13岁。希拉里·弗兰克讲述了关于她亲弟弟的故事。
This is what it sounds like when I call home to talk to my parents.
当我给父母打电话时，听起来就是这样。
[MUSIC - TRUMPET SCALES]
[音乐 - 小号音阶]
Whoever picks up has to go to another room, so they can hear me. It's been like this for six years. This is my 17 year old brother preparing for his future.
不管是谁接电话都得去另一个房间，这样他们才能听见我的声音。这种情况已经持续六年了。这就是我17岁的弟弟在为他的未来做准备。
I try and practice about five hours a day, four to five hours a day.
我尽量每天练习大约五个小时，四到五个小时。
Mom and Dad ever have to tell you to practice trumpet?
爸妈曾经要求你练小号吗？
No. Now, these days, they have to tell me to stop practicing. It might get to be like 11:00 or 12:00 and they want to go to bed, and they think the neighbors will be mad, so they have to tell me to stop.
不。如今，他们必须叫我停止练习。可能会到晚上11点或12点，他们想睡觉了，而且他们认为邻居会生气，所以他们必须叫我停止。
Josh is training to be a professional trumpeter. He calls the incessant practicing his insurance to guarantee he'll have the skills he needs in the future. During the week, he goes to a regular public high school. But on Saturdays, he devotes 15 hours of his day to Juilliard's pre-college program. Basically, it's like cramming everything you get in one week at a conservatory into one day.
乔什正在接受职业小号手的训练。他称这种坚持不懈的练习为他未来的技能保障。周内，他上一所普通的公立高中。但周六，他会全身心投入朱莉亚学院预科班15个小时。基本上，这就像把你在音乐学院一周要学的所有东西都压缩到一天里。
Josh is pretty obsessive about his horn. He brings it to school every day, just in case a class is canceled. When our family went on vacations, Josh was sure to have his trumpet. Then he got to a point where he told our parents he'd rather not go on vacation anymore. A week off could be better spent practicing. Five years ago, Josh gave up being a kid to play the trumpet.
乔什对他的号非常痴迷。他每天都带着它去学校，以防课被取消。我们全家去度假时，乔什一定会带着他的小号。后来到了一个地步，他告诉父母他宁愿不再去度假。一周的假期可以更好地用来练习。五年前，乔什放弃了做个孩子，选择了吹小号。
I can remember telling my friends what I was going to be doing. It was at the beach, and we were rollerblading, which was like the thing I did in 8th grade. We were gliding around the parking lot, and I was like, guys, guess what, I got into this pre-college program. And some of them didn't even know what Juilliard was.
我记得告诉朋友们我要做什么。那时在海滩上，我们正在溜旱冰，那是我八年级最喜欢做的事。我们滑过停车场，我当时说：“伙计们，猜怎么着，我进了这个预科班。”他们中有些人甚至不知道朱莉亚学院是什么。
Then it came, well, I guess you won't really be around on Saturdays. And I was like, I guess not. And it was difficult. The music was more important to me. And even if it does involve a sacrifice, I realized you couldn't have it both ways.
然后问题来了，好吧，我想你周六可能没法出现了。我说，大概吧。这很难。音乐对我来说更重要。即使这意味着牺牲，我也意识到你无法两全其美。
[MUSIC  - TRUMPET]
[音乐 - 小号]
In the first few years of high school, Josh used to call his friends to see what he was missing. They would tell him, oh, we just hung out until 3:00 in the morning, driving around or sitting at the diner, not very exciting. So Josh figured he wasn't missing much. When they invited him, he couldn't go. After a while, they stopped inviting him.
在高中头几年，乔什过去常打电话给朋友，看看他错过了什么。他们会告诉他：“噢，我们只是闲逛到凌晨3点，开车四处晃悠或坐在餐厅里，没什么意思。”所以乔什觉得他也没错过什么。当他们邀请他时，他去不了。过了一阵子，他们就不再邀请他了。
It wasn't until junior year that we just never saw anything of each other.
直到高二我们才基本断了联系。
This is Eric, one of Josh's old friends. They used to play in orchestra together at school.
这是埃里克，乔什的老朋友之一。他们过去常在学校管弦乐队一起演奏。
And then this year, I don't know. I meant to call him at the beginning of, end of summer, and I just never got around to it. And then I think we might have talked once or twice. Oh yeah, we played Frisbee at the beach a couple times. But then school started, Juilliard started, and Josh gets a little consumed. It's a relationship riddled with formalities, and there's really little substance left.
然后今年，我不知道。我本打算在夏天结束时给他打电话，但一直没腾出空。然后我想我们可能聊过一两次。哦对，我们在海滩玩过几次飞盘。但学校开始了，朱莉亚开始了，乔什变得有点沉迷其中。这成了一种充斥着礼节的关系，几乎没剩下什么实质内容了。
I got together with Eric and two other kids Josh has known since elementary school-- Katie and David. I wanted to know if they thought he was missing out. But like Eric, Katie and David said it was hard for them to talk about Josh. They told me they don't know him very well anymore. They all agreed. It's hard to put a label on what he's missed. All it is is a few hours of chilling time each week, when nothing really happens. But it all adds up.
我和埃里克以及乔什从小学就认识的另外两个孩子——凯蒂和大卫——聚在一起。我想知道他们是否认为他错过了什么。但像埃里克一样，凯蒂和大卫说他们觉得很难谈论乔什。他们告诉我，他们已经不太了解他了。他们一致认为，很难给他错过的内容贴上标签。那不过是每周几个小时的消磨时光，什么也没发生。但累积起来就不一样了。
Yeah, I'd say he's missing out on things, obviously, because he's not there. But if you asked, if he asked us what we did in a typical weekend, it wouldn't be a lot of great, life changing things. But I think on a whole, over a long period of time, he misses out on getting closer with friends that he could.
是的，我会说他错过了很多东西，显然，因为他不在场。但如果你问，如果他问我们周末通常做什么，那也没什么大事，不是什么改变人生的事。但我认为总的来说，在很长一段时间里，他错过了与原本可以更亲近的朋友培养感情的机会。
As our curfew was extended, we would stay out till 12:00 let's say. On Friday nights, he'd have to say at 10:00 or something, he'd say, OK, I'm going to Juilliard tomorrow, so I'll see you guys later. So that's two hours for us to kill without Josh, and eventually that adds up to a lot of hours to kill without Josh. Eventually that leads to, I think, it leads to Josh feeling alienated from his friends.
随着我们的宵禁时间延长，我们可以待到12点。周五晚上，他必须在10点左右说：“好的，我明天要去朱莉亚学院，所以改天再见。”所以那是我们可以消磨的两个小时，而乔什不在。最终加起来，就是很多没有乔什的时间。我想，这最终导致了乔什觉得与朋友疏离。
[MUSIC - TRUMPET]
[音乐 - 小号]
When Josh was in 8th grade and told me what he wanted to do, I worried about him, about what he was giving up. I thought he should have a normal high school experience, even though like a lot of people, I hated high school. I hated it so much I left a year early. But somehow, the myth of high school is so powerful that even those of us who despised it think that you're missing something important if you don't go. Josh goes to the same high school I did, and the time I think it's most painful for him is at lunch.
当乔什八年级告诉我他想做什么时，我很为他担心，担心他放弃了什么。我觉得他应该有正常的高中经历，尽管像很多人一样，我讨厌高中。我讨厌到提前一年离开了那里。但不知为何，高中的神话如此强大，以至于即使是我们这些鄙视它的人，也认为如果不上高中，就会错过什么重要的东西。乔什和我上的是同一所高中，而我认为这对他最痛苦的时候是在午餐时间。
It does suck. Basically, at every lunch period, lunch is like the big social time during school. And I don't like classes. I don't like my math class. I don't like going to that stuff. But the thing I most dread is lunch, because I have to figure out what I'm going to do for that half an hour. In the past, when I have sat at lunch with people, it's really awkward for me, because they're talking about what they are doing or what they're going to do. And I never feel included, which kind of separates me. And it's really painful. So the way I deal with it is to get into music more. Like maybe I'll practice during lunch. Instead of eating, I'll eat when I get home.
那确实很糟。基本上，每个午餐时段，午餐就像是学校里最重要的社交时间。我不喜欢上课。我不喜欢数学课。我不喜欢去处理那些事。但我最害怕的是午餐，因为我必须想清楚这半小时我要做什么。过去，当我和其他人一起吃午餐时，我感到非常尴尬，因为他们在谈论他们正在做什么或打算做什么。我从没感到被包容，这把我孤立了。这真的很痛苦。所以我应对的方式是更多地投入到音乐中。比如我可能在午餐时练习。我不吃饭，回家再吃。
[MUSIC - TRUMPET]
[音乐 - 小号]
Today, all of Josh's close relationships are with other musicians. They connect easily, without having to explain their motivations for working so hard. And they have their own social scene, although it's not typical of kids their age.
今天，乔什所有的亲密关系都是与其他音乐家建立的。他们很容易就联系在一起，无需解释他们为何如此努力工作。他们有自己的社交圈，尽管这在他们这个年龄的孩子中并不典型。
My friend often throws parties out of his apartment called sight reading parties. It's mostly string players and piano players who get together and just read music. And then when you're not reading, you just hang out and have a good time and listen to the music.
我的朋友经常在他的公寓里举办派对，叫视奏派对。大多数是弦乐手和钢琴家聚在一起，只是读谱。当你不在读谱时，你们就闲逛，享受美好时光，听听音乐。
You're describing this as your favorite social experience, and it's doing exactly what you would be doing if you were working in your ideal job.
你形容这是你最喜欢的社交体验，而这正是你理想工作时要做的事情。
Totally.
完全正确。
Back when he was little, Josh took violin and piano, and our mom used to set the timer in the kitchen to make sure he practiced for half an hour. He quit those instruments. It was just torture, getting him to sit for that long. But with the trumpet, it's almost as if he can't help himself.
当他小的时候，乔什学过小提琴和钢琴，我妈妈过去常在厨房里定个定时器，确保他练习半小时。他放弃了那些乐器。让他坐那么久简直是一种折磨。但有了小号，他几乎是无法自拔。
I can't explain it. It's just, it was right. It was just meant to happen.
我无法解释。它就是……对了。注定要发生。
But I'm going to press you on this a little bit more. Why, what was so different about it? There had to be some difference. Was it because you were using your mouth, or?
但我还得再逼问你一下。为什么？它有什么不同？肯定有什么区别。是因为你在用嘴巴，还是？
I think it was the sound. Just the sound that the trumpet made, I always thought was really beautiful. It sounds really warm, and you can really sing on it. You can be the soprano, or you can be in the orchestra, and be the biggest pig, and when you're playing Wagner, just play really loud and really brilliantly. Just to be a part of something like that is really special.
我认为是声音。小号发出的那种声音，我一直认为非常美。它听起来非常温暖，你真的可以用它来歌唱。你可以是女高音，或者你可以在管弦乐队里，做个最响亮的人。当你在演奏瓦格纳时，吹得又响又灿烂。能成为其中的一部分，真的很特别。
[MUSIC - TRUMPET]
[音乐 - 小号]
It's amazing to adults when a 13 year old announces he or she has made a major life decision, and then sticks with it. One of the most adult things you can do is make a choice. Give up something fun in favor of something else. Though Josh says he won't really feel like an adult until he's doing his own laundry, getting his own groceries, ironing his own dress shirt before performances, living on his own.
当一个13岁的孩子宣布他或她做出了重大的生活决定，然后坚持下去时，成年人会感到惊讶。你能做的最成年人的事情之一就是做出选择。为了别的东西放弃一些有趣的事情。尽管乔什说，直到他能自己洗衣服、自己买菜、表演前自己熨烫衬衫、独立生活时，他才真正觉得像个成年人。
Hilary Frank is an art student living in New York City.
希拉里·弗兰克是一位住在纽约市的艺术系学生。
[MUSIC - "I AM A CHILD" BY NEIL YOUNG]
[音乐 - 尼尔·杨的《我是一个孩子》]
Act 4, Angry Young Man, Times Two. This is the story of two people, one in his late teens, one in his late 50's. And we'll start with the older man. Willie Ross grew up in Arkansas in the 1940's, picked cotton from the time he was eight. He was a big strong kid.
第四幕，《愤怒的年轻人，乘以二》。这是两个人的故事，一个接近成年，一个接近花甲之年。我们从年纪较大的人开始。威利·罗斯在20世纪40年代的阿肯色州长大，八岁起就开始采摘棉花。他是个强壮的孩子。
And we're going to field. I was going out there with my mother at five, six, seven years old. And I had fast hands, I noticed, and because watching her, you had to gather cotton real fast, because how great a cotton picker she was. And when I got 12, I was the only kid was picking 250 pound at 12 years old.
我们要去田里。我五、六、七岁时就跟着我母亲去那里。我注意到我的手很快，因为看着她，你必须采摘得非常快，因为她是一位多么出色的棉花采摘工啊。当我12岁时，我是唯一一个12岁就能摘250磅棉花的孩子。
When Willie Ross was 13, his stepfather died, and just months later, his mother died too, of spinal meningitis. And after the funeral, Willie Ross headed back to the family's house in Helena, Arkansas.
威利·罗斯13岁时，继父去世了，仅几个月后，母亲也因脊髓脑膜炎去世了。葬礼后，威利·罗斯回到了阿肯色州海伦娜的家里。
When I caught the bus and went back to Helena, when I got to my address, which was 1136 Pecan Street, I looked there and the house was empty. There was no furniture, there was nothing.
当我坐公共汽车回到海伦娜，到达我的地址——佩肯街1136号时，我看到房子是空的。没有家具，什么都没有。
One of his sisters, who was pregnant and in the 12th grade, had taken all the furniture and went to live with her boyfriend.
他的一位正在读高三且怀孕的姐姐，把所有的家具都带走了，去和男朋友同住。
They had moved away, and no one took me in. I mean, I didn't know anything, and they had their own life. And I guess they was telling me about steel mills. Some of my family figured that I could get a job. I was big for my age, but I did not want that.
他们搬走了，没有人收留我。我的意思是，我什么都不懂，他们有自己的生活。我想他们当时在跟我说钢铁厂的事。我的一些亲戚认为我可以找份工作。我长得比同龄人强壮，但我不想那样。
Here's how he made it on his own, as a freshman in high school. His sister's boyfriend helped him rent a room in town, another sister, he says, sent him $24 a month. Of that, 12 covered his rent. He learned to budget, he washed his own clothes, made his own meals. People from church looked out for him. Boy Scouts was a big part of his life all through school. He played sports. He turned to God. And he supported himself with a series of jobs that relied on raw physical strength. He worked on an ice truck, on a beer truck, on a soda truck, carrying heavy crates of bottles. And he boxed.
这就是他作为高中新生如何独立生活的经过。他姐姐的男朋友帮他在城里租了个房间，他说另一位姐姐每个月给他寄24美元。其中12美元付房租。他学会了理财，洗自己的衣服，做自己的饭。教会的人照顾着他。童子军是他整个学校生活的重要部分。他参加体育运动。他转向了上帝。他靠着一系列依靠纯体力活的工作养活自己。他在冰块卡车、啤酒卡车、苏打水卡车上工作，搬运沉重的瓶子箱。他还参加拳击。
At 5'11", I didn't have the arm reach, but I was powerful, and I was quick. So what I did, I found that people would notice me, and give me hugs, if I'd be good in sports. Beating people up. I mean, I thought it was crazy. I said, here I am, nobody knows me as a person. But they love me as a violent animal. And I thought it was crazy, but you know, unfortunately, that's where I got my love, because everybody's attention came to me in sports. And I had a lot of hurt in my heart, because when your mother die, you are angry. And you wonder why other people got mothers, and you couldn't. I couldn't understand that. And so boxing, I just enjoyed beating them up.
身高5英尺11英寸，我的臂展没优势，但我强壮，而且敏捷。所以我发现，如果我在体育运动中表现出色，人们会注意到我，并给我拥抱。打架。我的意思是，我觉得这太疯狂了。我说，我在这里，没人作为一个人了解我。但他们作为暴力动物爱着我。我觉得这很疯狂，但不幸的是，那就是我获得爱的方式，因为大家的注意力都集中在我的体育表现上。我的心中有很多创伤，因为当你的母亲去世时，你是愤怒的。你奇怪为什么其他人都有母亲，而你却没有。我无法理解。所以拳击，我只是享受痛打他们。
So you were pretty angry as a teenager. When did that turn?
所以你在少年时期非常愤怒。那是什么时候转变的？
I don't think it turned. I'm still fighting it. You know, every day I think about it.
我不认为转变了。我还在与它斗争。你知道，我每天都在想这件事。
He played football in high school, and was just as violent a football player as he was a boxer, he says. He went to college on a football scholarship, played pro ball for the Buffalo Bills, winning two championships on a team led by Jack Kemp. After that, he became a cop, and finally ended up an assistant superintendent at the Audi Home, a juvenile detention center in Chicago. Which is, as far as anybody seems to know, the largest juvenile lockup in the world. Sometimes as many as 600 kids behind bars, many of them full of anger. And full of anger for justifiable reasons, understandable reasons. Like Mr. Ross, back when he was their age.
他在高中打橄榄球，他说，他在球场上和拳击场上一样暴力。他靠橄榄球奖学金上了大学，在布法罗比尔队打了职业联赛，赢得了两届冠军，当时球队由杰克·肯普领导。之后，他成了警察，最终成为了芝加哥奥迪之家（Audi Home）——一个少年拘留中心——的助理主管。据大家所知，这是世界上最大的少年看守所。有时有600名孩子被关在铁窗后，他们许多人心中充满了愤怒。而且这种愤怒有正当的、可以理解的理由。就像罗斯先生当年那个年纪一样。
I really was angry, and I really hurt, because I couldn't understand why none of my people took me in. And I was a good kid. And I see these kids, it's happening to them.
我真的很生气，我真的感到受伤，因为我不明白为什么没有一个亲人收留我。我曾经是个好孩子。我看到这些孩子，这种事正发生在他们身上。
These kids here.
这些在这里的孩子。
These kids who locked up here in juvenile detention center. It happened to them. And I stress them, it happened to me. But I've told them this. Set a goal. Get an education.
这些被关在少年拘留中心里的孩子。这种事发生在他们身上。我强调，这种事也发生在我身上。但我告诉他们：设定一个目标。接受教育。
One of the many kids Mr. Ross told his stories to was Terence Golden. Terence describes his own life this way. Until he was nine, he says, he did well in school, things were fine. And then it all fell apart, when his father died of cancer.
罗斯先生讲述这些故事的孩子之一是特伦斯·戈登（Terence Golden）。特伦斯这样描述自己的生活。他说，在九岁之前，他在学校表现很好，一切都很好。然后当他父亲死于癌症时，一切都崩溃了。
From there, that's like where the problems begin, you know, it's been hard since then. He died, my brother got killed, my cousin died, my grandmother died, so it's been a lot of trials and tribulations.
从那时起，那是问题开始的地方，你知道，从那以后就一直很艰难。他死了，我哥哥被杀了，我表亲死了，我祖母死了，所以经历了很多磨难。
And then what happened in your life after that? How did things change for you?
那之后你的生活发生了什么？事情是怎么改变的？
I started to change mentally, you know? Go about things the wrong way, don't express myself, hold in anger, and there's a build up. It's like, when it's ready to go, it's like a volcano blow.
我的心理开始发生改变，你知道吗？以错误的方式做事，不表达自己，压抑愤怒，这是一种积压。就像，当它准备爆发时，就像火山喷发一样。
Were you really close to your dad?
你和你父亲很亲吗？
I was the closest person in my family I've ever been close to. I was closer to him than my mother. When he died, my mother tried to bring me closer. But I really didn't want to grow closer. I wanted my father. And she was trying to tell me, she told me all the right things. But in my own little world, I thought it was wrong.
他是我家庭里我曾经最亲近的人。我比跟我母亲还要亲。当他去世时，我母亲试图带我亲近。但我真的不想更亲近。我想要我的父亲。她试图告诉我，她告诉我所有正确的事情。但在我自己的小世界里，我觉得那是错的。
Terence started doing badly in school, didn't listen to anybody, got it all sorts of trouble, and finally was arrested at the age of 14 for murder. A gang shooting with three other guys.
特伦斯在学校的表现开始变差，不听任何人的话，惹上了各种麻烦，最终在14岁时因谋杀罪被捕。那是与另外三个家伙的帮派枪击案。
And once he was behind bars, he started to think about things, and calm down. And he seemed to change. He befriended some adults, wrote and acted in some plays with the theater group, plays in which he and other teenagers contemplated the consequences of their crimes. He stayed at the Audi Home for two years as his case worked its way through the courts.
一旦他被关进铁窗，他开始思考事情，冷静了下来。他似乎变了。他结交了一些成年人，在戏剧组编写并表演了一些剧目，在这些剧目中，他和另外的青少年思考了他们犯罪的后果。他在奥迪之家待了两年，等待案件通过法院审理。
Finally, a verdict came down. He was found guilty of murder. But he made enough of an impression on the adults in the lockup that several who rarely testify on behalf of any kids chose to testify for Terence at a sentencing hearing, hoping to convince the judge that he was worth taking a chance on.
最终，判决下来了。他被判谋杀罪成立。但他给看守所里的成年人留下了足够的印象，以至于几位很少为孩子作证的人，选择在量刑听证会上为特伦斯作证，希望说服法官他值得给一次机会。
One of these adults was Meade Palidofsky, of the theater group Music Theater Workshop, who'd spent months working closely with Terence. Over ten years, out of hundreds of kids she's worked with behind bars, she's only testified for four or five. She says Terence was a natural leader, worked hard, had a sense of humor, got along with everybody.
其中一位成年人是音乐戏剧工作坊（Music Theater Workshop）的米德·帕里多夫斯基（Meade Palidofsky），她与特伦斯密切合作了几个月。十年来，在她工作过的数百个铁窗后的孩子中，她只为四五个人作过证。她说特伦斯是一位天生的领袖，工作努力，有幽默感，和每个人都能相处得很好。
Terence grieved in a way that I don't often see kids. And my criteria, basically, is whether I think the kid has something to offer, whether they have remorse, whether if they went back out into the world-- I mean, the basic question I ask myself is, would I invite this child to stay at my house? Would I bring them into my house, would I offer them a job, would I help them out?
特伦斯悲伤的方式是我不常在孩子身上看到的。我的准则基本上是，判断这个孩子是否还有救，是否有悔意，如果他们回到这个世界……我的意思是，我问自己的基本问题是：我会邀请这个孩子待在我家吗？我会把他带进我的房子，我会给他提供工作，我会帮助他吗？
And if the answer is yes, then I'll go to court. Because there are some kids that I really like who I wouldn't. Because I think that although I like very much, if they went out on the street, they'd be right back into it. But for Terence, there was a lot of us that really believed in him.
如果答案是肯定的，那我就去法庭。因为有些孩子我真的很喜欢，但我不会。因为我认为，虽然我很喜欢他们，但如果他们回到街头，他们会立刻重操旧业。但对于特伦斯，我们很多人真的信任他。
Terence also asked Willie Ross to testify on his behalf. Mr. Ross turned him down. Liberals tend to think about cases like this one way, conservatives think about them another. Willie Ross's thinking takes in both sides. He'll give you the liberal line. He'll tell you that the only difference between him and Terence is that sports programs, church programs, and other positive community activities were there for Mr. Ross. And that's what saved him. That's what Terence never had.
特伦斯也请求威利·罗斯为他作证。罗斯先生拒绝了他。自由派倾向于以一种方式考虑这类案件，保守派则以另一种方式。威利·罗斯的思考方式兼顾了双方。他会给你自由派的观点。他会告诉你，他和特伦斯之间唯一的区别是，体育项目、教堂项目和其他积极的社区活动当时对罗斯先生来说是存在的。而那是拯救他的东西。那是特伦斯从未拥有过的。
And he'll give you the conservative line. That any 14 year old or 12 year old who shoots somebody knows exactly what he's doing, and should serve an adult punishment. Which, in Mr. Ross's point of view, should be the death penalty.
他也会给你保守派的观点。任何14岁或12岁枪杀某人的人都确切地知道他在做什么，应该受到成人的惩罚。在罗斯先生看来，那应该是死刑。
And this kid, and everybody, Mr. Ross, and he asked me to go to court. I would not go to court with him. I do not go to court for a murder. Period. For some things, you know, but not violent crime. I found him, and he found me too late. It's sad, but it happened. One of the things I tell the kids, I believe in the death penalty.
这个孩子，每个人，罗斯先生，他让我去法庭。我不会去为他作证的。我不去为谋杀案作证。期间。有些事我知道，但暴力犯罪不行。我发现他太晚了，他也发现我太晚了。这很可悲，但它确实发生了。我告诉孩子们的一件事是，我支持死刑。
Even for a 12, 13, 14 year old kid who shoots somebody?
即使是对12、13、14岁的枪杀别人的孩子？
Yes. I believe that. Because I was 12, 13, and I knew better. I had a rifle at nine years old. And yet, still, I had more judgement than pull the trigger, and with all the anger I had.
是的。我相信这一点。因为我曾12岁、13岁，我懂事。我九岁就有步枪了。然而，尽管我心中满是愤怒，但我仍然比扣动扳机的人更有判断力。
For years now, states have been cracking down on juvenile crime, sentencing teenagers and even preteens as adults in some places. We expect young people who face adversity now to master their emotions and overcome it. Terence was tried as an adult, and sentenced as an adult to 40 years. One year ago this week, at the age of 17, he entered a maximum security prison in Joliet, Illinois. It's not like the Audi Home, where there are counselors and classes and activities, and acknowledgement that these are kids that might be rehabilitatable.
多年来，各州一直在打击青少年犯罪，在某些地方将青少年甚至未成年人作为成年人判刑。我们期望现在面对逆境的年轻人能够控制情绪并克服它。特伦斯被当作成年人审判，并被作为成年人判处40年监禁。一年前的本周，17岁的他进入了伊利诺伊州乔利埃特的一所最高安全级别监狱。那不像奥迪之家，那里有咨询师、课程和活动，承认这些孩子是可以被改造的。
Oh, it's a lot different. The officers, they different.
哦，那太不同了。警官们，他们不同。
How are they different?
他们怎么不同？
They more aggressive. A lot of them ain't out to help you. You might catch a few that's out to help you. But there ain't too many out there for you. The inmate's different. See there, it's more laid back. See, here, you got to watch, you know? Watch continuously what's around you.
他们更有侵略性。他们中很多人不是来帮助你的。你可能会遇到少数愿意帮助你的。但没有多少人是真心为你的。囚犯们也不同。在那儿，更放松。你看，在这儿，你必须观察，你知道吗？持续观察你周围的情况。
Did you feel safe at the Audi Home?
你在奥迪之家感到安全吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Do you feel safe here?
你在这儿感到安全吗？
It's all in the mind. It's a mind game. I can make myself feel safe. I don't talk to nobody, really. I stay to myself, so I feel safe.
一切都在心中。这是一种心理博弈。我能让自己感到安全。我不和任何人说话，真的。我保持独处，所以我感到安全。
He's been going to church in prison. He says it's hard to stay on the straight and narrow. If he doesn't get into trouble, he'll serve 20 years of his 40 year sentence.
他在监狱里参加礼拜。他说保持正轨很难。如果他不惹麻烦，他将服完40年刑期中的20年。
Our program was produced today by Blue Chevigny and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Susan Burton, Julie Snyder, and Starlee Kine. Contributing editors Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, Margie Rochlin, Alix Spiegel, Nancy Updike, and consigliere Sarah Vowell. Production help from Todd Bachmann.
今天的节目由布鲁·谢维尼（Blue Chevigny）和我制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格、苏珊·伯顿、朱莉·斯奈德和斯塔莉·凯恩参与制作。特约编辑：保罗·托夫、杰克·希特、玛吉·罗奇林、阿里克斯·斯皮格尔、南希·厄普代克，以及智囊萨拉·沃威尔。托德·巴赫曼提供制作帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
To buy a cassette of this or any of our programs, call us here at WBEZ in Chicago. 312-832-3380. Or you know, you can listen to most of our programs for free on the internet, at our website at www.thislife.org where we include all sorts of stuff we can't fit on the radio show. Thanks to Elizabeth Meister who runs the site. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. Funding for our program is provided by Amazon.com. The books and music on This American Life are available on Amazon.com. [FUNDING CREDITS]
要购买本期或我们任何节目的盒式磁带，请致电我们在芝加哥的WBEZ电台。312-832-3380。或者你知道，你可以在我们的网站www.thislife.org免费收听我们的大部分节目，我们在那里包含了各种各样无法放入广播节目的内容。感谢负责运营网站的伊丽莎白·迈斯特。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台（PRI）发行。我们节目的资金由Amazon.com提供。《美国生活》中的书籍和音乐可在Amazon.com上购买。[资金赞助名单]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who just popped in, just popped his head in the door with this question,
WBEZ管理监督：托里·马拉蒂亚。他刚刚推门进来，问了这个问题：
"What the hell do you think you're doing, booby?"
“你到底在搞什么鬼，笨蛋？”
I'm Ira Glass, back next week, with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
"Did anyone tell you we're dealing with human lives here?"
“有没有人告诉过你，我们处理的是人命？”
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。